it chapter 2 is finally heaven as of
this taping does not yet have a tomato
meter score but early social reactions
to the film are having people liking it
but not loving it saying it's a little
too long but that Bill Hader is a
standout are all these things true let's
find out hi everyone I'm Mark Ellis and
welcome to the after show fair warning
if you've not yet seen it chapter 2 this
is a spoiler heavy discussion so you've
been warned I am thrilled to be joined
by a panel full of individual winners
but United they become my losers Club
the first one of them is Rotten Tomatoes
editor Jack wood Koli hello glad to be
back and we have the editor-in-chief of
Rotten Tomatoes mr. Joel Mears is on the
couch good morning mark we also have
live from Toronto via Skype he is the
editor-in-chief of Dredd Central mr.
Jonathan bark on making his debut on the
show how you doing bud I'm doing very
well thank you for having me
Toronto still celebrating that
championship and getting ready for that
little Film Festival that you guys have
coming up in a couple of weeks right
something small TIFF I don't know if
anyone's ever heard of it I know
Jacqueline has and I know her her bags
are already packed so let's get right
into this discussion I love teeing up
the panelists to see if you thought the
movie was fresher rod so Joel I want to
start with you on that just tell me if
this movie is fresh or rotten and maybe
a reason why you feel that way well it's
a deeply flawed frickin long but I think
ultimately it's fresh okay I can't say
over the line all right
yes apply now you've got a buildup but I
think it's gonna be caveat so we're
gonna get at those caveats but this is
ultimately a fresh three hours all right
it's a barely fresh for Joel it's
approaching that expiration date
Jonathan do you agree with Joel's just a
fresh movie in your eyes I'm gonna go
ahead and give it a fresh but I will
agree that there is a lot of cons along
the of a lot of pros a lot of content a
lot of pros Jack wood Kohli is this
movie fresh super fresh barely fresh
well as the president founder of the
Bill Hader Stan Club this is about as
fresh
movie can get cuz he is the man in it
however I will admit absent him I don't
know if this movie would pass the fresh
marker because it he really made the
movie and I gotta thank Andy was sketti
for casting him because without it don't
know if it would be there yeah I was
gonna say your boy came to play in this
one so we're gonna get into the cast a
little bit later in this episode but
right off the bat I'm gonna say that I
think this movie's fresh but I echo my
panelists concerns that there's a length
issue that this felt like a different
movie than maybe what I think a lot of
people are being advertised it as even
though we did get a lot of Pennywise so
all that coming later on in this show
right now I just want to ask Jacqueline
I'm gonna start with you because I know
you read the book so this feels like a
very faithful adaptation to the book I'm
allergic to reading but this is what I'm
hearing
so does it stay faithful and if so was
that the right choice it does stay
faithful to the book and I think for a
lot of people that will be debated it
depends on how you feel about the book
whether it was a good choice there were
elements in the first book that they
deleted there's like a sexual thing that
they got rid of and in fact the opening
scene of this movie is actually I
believe in chapter one in the Quran a
lot in the chronologically yeah in the
whatever in the timeline sorry
so this one I feel is faithful but they
still deleted some things that needed to
be deleted there's a whole domestic
storyline violence thing with Jessica
Chastain's husband a kidnap thing that
they deleted he got rid of a lot of the
more problematic elements of this
because it is sort of a dated story but
I think that it's still great that he
did it the way that he did and I liked
that it had each individual beats that's
also why it didn't feel as long for me
because I knew what was coming I knew it
the like hour and a half mark I was like
oh we still have a lot more to go so I
wasn't necessarily is like how long is
this gonna take
Jonathan did you read it and and if so
did the feel like a true adaptation was
that the right play in your eyes
I did read it but I'll be completely
honest the last time I read that book
was approximately 20 maybe even 25 years
ago so it's been a long time that being
said the movie feels very much like a
king adaptation it plays out exactly
way that Kings stories unfold and it
felt very if you were to watch it not
knowing that it was a Stephen King story
I really feel like you would walk away
thinking that's something that Stephen
King wrote Jolie did you read the book
as well am I the only guy that didn't
know I'm like you I read it Christopher
Pike is about as far as I came letter
but no but I would have grace Jonathan
that and you know having read some
Stephen King seen a lot of his films
this does feel very Stephen King and it
brings in a lot of the Stephen King
weirdness which I think was actually a
little bit absent from the first film
where they did a more sort of
streamlined scary clown kind of telling
this one went oh no we're just gonna get
bat [ __ ] and throw all the way it
shouldn't and I think people will be put
off by that I actually like that because
I found it some of the more surprising
elements of the film yeah I mean I'm
seeing a lot of people say that this
movie is too long so Jonathan has
somebody who you read the book basically
as long as go is the last time we saw
any wise in the mythology of it do you
think that there's any way to make this
movie shorter than what it was or was
this the runtime that we needed to have
I think this is the runtime that we
needed to have however I think that the
film could have been edited a little
tighter and there could have been some
elements expanded upon while others were
shrunk down a little I think the problem
with this film was that it didn't use
its three hours in the best way possible
okay give me an example of that as far
as maybe what happens in the climax
because if my personal opinion is that
the climax it was you know it felt like
okay now it's time to take care of this
thing once and for all but it did feel a
little dragged out to me anyway
yeah that's actually the perfect example
is the kind of final battle with penny
wise the series of events there just
felt like it took too long the scene
when Bill and Eddie were at the three
doors the not scary at all scary and
very scary it felt like it just dragged
on a little too long specifically the
scene with the cute little dog
admittedly it's a really charming a very
funny scene but I did find myself at a
moment going
you've said the same thing three times
it's time to move on as somebody who has
a cute little dog and loves one of the
actors in that scene Jack and Koli
that's single ones belong for you what
was the scene that you felt like could
have been tightened up no that's
definitely one that could have left and
the main reason why I think is a Nima's
sketti loves this book and you can tell
that he loves this book and so I do
think it was hard for him to let some of
these scenes go and that's a great scene
to put on a DVD as a bonus feature like
hey we cut this out but it's great but
because he loved it so much he kept it
in I would also say that in the very
beginning as once they realized that
they know they need to go back and get
Pennywise before we get to the carnival
that whole section could be way
tightened up I do feel they should have
played off of the bill like the the
James McAvoy Jessica Chastain romance
throw that away way quicker than they
did they played that for way longer than
it needed to and they needed to actually
get to our actual love interest again
these are all things that happen in the
book and that's kind of how the book is
you get very frustrated that she thinks
that bill is the one but I just you know
get get to the good stuff I have some
serious edit look I know that machete is
very faithful to this book but I didn't
think we need power the bully coming
back I was like if you're gonna do away
with a storyline that feels like it
could be cleanly cut 25 minutes there
I'll go through it the same we're just
kids Chastain is assaulted at her house
in the beginning if you're not gonna
follow that character through who's in
the book don't bother that scene felt
totally out of place
that's another few minutes the climax
too much spider it I'm done with you
stop I would rather have the three doors
and the giant spider for another bloody
20 minutes to sort of languishing in the
cave I'm decided it could be there's
serious edits that could be even before
we got to the climax I just I I never
felt like the stakes were all that high
for each individual loser when they went
on their quest to go get their artifact
after we see the first couple and it's
like okay you're all gonna realize the
same exact thing then oh I need to
conquer my fear and none of this is real
so I'm gonna be okay that's like an hour
in the movie that we that we get taken
out so maybe
you could have tightened it up there but
when we get to the ending here and and
the wrap-up of it chapter 2 and possibly
the it franchise Jonathan I want to toss
it to you first
was it a satisfying conclusion to this
story for you I mean it was the
conclusion that we needed to get it's
what the story offered it's the
characters kind of followed their
natural progression from the children to
the adults and ultimately we did get the
the ending that we deserved admittedly
it took a little longer to get there
than the necessary but I felt I felt
happy with how it ended yeah and Joe the
temptation here as we've seen in a lot
of horror movies recently is to have
something hint that oh well maybe it's
not done yet but I I'm actually happy
for the losers that they get to move on
with their lives yeah I think so I
thought it was a relatively satisfying
ending I think people will have some
issues with the idea that the alcohol at
the Infinity stones quest didn't quite
actually didn't quite it didn't quite
work well the whole crux is didn't quite
work and that that it was just kind of a
repeat of have a semi defeated him in
the first chapter which is a pretty
obvious conclusion if he's the
manifestation of your fears not to be
afraid
took them a little long to get there so
I think there will be that
dissatisfaction but I ultimately liked
it and I thought there was an almost
poignancy to the way that Pennywise
deflated in the end and then dissipated
and dusted again infinity but yeah I
just I I feel like I was satisfied I
think certain audience members may not
be you can follow Joel on Twitter for
all of his Avengers endgame it chapter 2
parallels were saved in the elevator
about all of the similarities that you
get with those two movies Jacqueline the
final word goes to you was this wrap-up
worth it
I was I think for one specific reason
and I cannot quote this because it was a
little while ago that I read it but I
think they moved Stanley's letter
Stanley's letter which you know
basically sorry this is a spoiler show
Stanley's dead uh-huh any writes a
letter as to why he can't join the
losers and I think in the book that's
given earlier then it's given in the
and having him sort of tie that up with
that nice bow I felt was very a poignant
and sort of like it you know I I shed a
tear for that moment I was like this is
exactly where it needs to be and then of
course my cinematic soul mate mr. Bill
Hader with his name etched onto the
bridge you know Ritchie and Eddie
forever that really also like touched my
heart it was a nice wrap up and on the
way was a lot more Pennywise than what
we got to see in the first movie and I
love how scary clowns are to people I'm
not a huge fan of clowns
but I'm they're not keeping me up at
night but Pennywise just does something
on that poster to audiences around the
world a couple years ago in the first it
came out so Joel was more penny wise the
right decision in this film was he is
scarier penny wise to you I think he was
a same effect penny wise I never found
penny wise particularly frightening I
found him intriguing and almost
sympathetic at time you were pulling for
him I wasn't pulling well you know given
how the decisions and some of these guys
made maybe I was but I you know I think
it was the only way they could have gone
as filmmakers because penny wise had
become this this image and this icon for
many people who were fans of the
original film that you could only go
more penny wise I did not love the
alternatives to penny wise which were
often just CGI
crap I would say so I would I would much
prefer them face off with penny wise
than another version of a leper or
another version of something else that
has been conjured in a computer that's
interesting so Jonathan do you share
that sentiment that joel has where penny
wise himself is a scary clown and that
that's good enough to be the Vil and
then when we get all these other CGI
monsters they don't really have the
payoff that was intended
I think the CGI monsters are actually
incredibly fascinating because of the
fact that they are the manifestation of
each of the losers fears and I think
that by virtue of the fact that they're
adults their fears are deeper they're
darker and so we saw some much more
terrifying visuals this time that being
said I will agree that some of the CG on
these creatures was very poor it looks
like basically it was ripped straight
of a Silent Hill videogame but when it
worked it worked incredibly well which
was your favorite if you you've got to
pick one alternate Pennywise
manifestation do you have one that
sticks out there I'm very scared of
spiders
so the thing Gamache when the head
started sprouting that limbs and even
one came out from the eye that
definitely kind of made me squirm in my
seat but if it weren't that when it
would be when bill is reaching his arm
into the sewer for georgie and his arm
is grabbed and hundreds of little hands
and arms start appearing and crawling
all over him I thought that was
wonderful
yeah those ninja turtles are dealing
with some scary stuff were there Jack my
favorite what was actually one that you
didn't see it was cool seeing the huge
Paul Bunyan go after Richie but my
favorite scene in that my favorite part
of that scene is when Richie looks back
and he doesn't see the statue and we
have that panic for a minute like oh
here comes Paul Bunyan that was it for
me what was it for you
um the one that he mentioned with the
eyeball and I guess that was Stanley's
head and like that was that creeped me
out beyond belief also the dinner table
when the cockroaches started coming out
like that was very freaky and then
basically figuring out you know Stanley
couldn't cut it that was just that whole
scene went from jovial and reunion and
happiness to just so dark so quickly the
history of cinema Joel is littered with
these great villains that don't get a
lot of screen time and it's the mystery
of what could be of what works
underneath the water with the shark from
Jaws Hannibal Lector the t-rex in
Jurassic Park you don't see a lot of
them on screen so do you think that too
much Pennywise perhaps made him that
sympathetic figure that you were talking
about I don't know because again I
didn't I never found him particularly
terrifying and when he's not on screen
the alternative is one of these these
monsters so you know I think in a
different world with a different
director perhaps and if they hadn't
conjured such an iconic image they may
have chosen to go that Jaws route and it
might have been scarier but that's not
the film we have and it's a little bit
hard to assess I will say on the the
monster discussion the one
the most disappointing was mrs. Kirsch I
think it's it's Kirsch isn't it the yeah
she was amazing but then at the end when
she ran out and suddenly she was a CGI
monster which I actually don't think in
the originally an original trailer she
was it was the actual grandmother who
was the the older lady who was running
towards the screen and that was so much
more frightening when she was just human
than when she was this sort of new
invention and I was like ah why'd you do
that
come on so I have the pleasure of going
to the it to premiere and then the
after-party afterwards they had a booth
set up where you could take a picture
with a lady who's playing the role of
Miss Esther they had the whole living
room set up so I took a picture I'm
sitting there next to what from my
memories ray finkles mom she's just as
crazy person making new cookies and
she's about to kill you and that she
never broke character the entire time it
was a whole lot of fun let's move on to
the losers club because I know at least
one panelist is dying to talk about it
before I get the Jaclyn's take on her
favorite loser which I can predict
Jonathan I want to toss it over to you
your your take on the losers Club on the
casting it seems to be critically what
one of the highlights of this movie is
does that ring true for you absolutely
it was perfect casting everyone not only
physically resembled their younger
selves but they somehow managed to
really hone in on what made each of
those characters so unique and gave them
such a charming quality and they brought
that into their adult selves that being
said I think that the standout for me
would be Jay Ryan I think it was as Ben
Hanscom for someone that is so that is a
an Adonis like character he's a Greek
statue and at one point I even joked
Yuri as he's getting carved in the
stomach by Pennywise he's hunched over
and yet he still has an eight-pack what
I think this is it's a great opportunity
for him to show the ABS that he has
acquired to the love of his life it's
like I know this really hurts but check
out i got an ab roller yeah so even with
all of that he still had that lack of
confidence that uncertainty that kind of
boyish unaware how to move forward it
was i think he really did a fantastic
job of being an adult then and as a
chubby kid we all now have something new
to aspire to with an i Joel your
favorite member of the losers glad I
also would echo that Jay Ryan was
probably the best performance and I felt
captured the original character and it
wasn't just mimicry of the original
character you actually saw the growth
and got the sense of where his life had
been lots of Jim I would also say
obviously I know what you're gonna say
so yes I agree with you he was an
absolute highlight but Eddie mr. Renne
James Rahon James Ransone really good
casting there as well
I think McEvoy and Chastain were good
and you can't really fault their
performances but they perhaps had the
least interesting arcs and characters to
go with so I don't think they were as
perhaps engaging as some of the others
and I think some of the stuff that
McAvoy was made to do slash screaming a
kid in the street felt a little bit
maybe that would some might say that was
not the best choice from director or
actor right I think of what when you go
back to character arc Jacqueline I think
it some might say it's a no-brainer that
it would be Ben's character arc that
gets the most even certainly me from my
youth that but then as an adult I think
I can relate a lot to some of the things
that Ritchie's going through being a
stand-up comic he's he's a comic in the
books I had no idea yeah if I remember
correctly I believe you they're all the
same like yeah Ben's an architect he's a
comic because again in the book he's
cracking successful little group of
friends yes really are which I also
think is really interesting before I get
to Ritchie and mr. Bill Hader let's talk
about Isaiah Mustafa who's this huge
hulking very buff like not intimidating
guy he's like a nice guy but just his
stature is just so like
like that more that Adonis character how
he was able to wind himself back and
become this almost like guileless and
very almost like Chris Pratt and in
Parks and Recreation just lost but
trying to find a way to make this work
that was a real transformation from
anything he's done it showed a lot of
range because I think the Old Spice guy
would have this whole situation resolved
in 20 minutes because he's the the the
he still has all those nerves and and I
love that it's just dripping on-screen
how he feels because he has never been
able to leave Derry and get out of this
mindset and that that all came through
in his performance so I definitely want
to shout out and again all the losers
but of course missile bill bill hader my
cinematic soul mates stole the show he
was funny he was heartwarming he really
showed his range like if folks didn't
see the movie that he did a few years
ago the skeleton twins where he kind of
showed this vulnerability that he can
bring forth and if you're not watching
Barry maybe you don't know this but this
is what I've always said with comedians
and why they make such good dramatic
actors it is harder to make people laugh
and it is to make them cry and it's
really about tapping into how to
manipulate an audience and he is
brilliant at doing that and he does it
in so many just small and subtle ways
the fact that he can turn you from a
joke to a tear within 30 seconds is I
don't know definitely something that
needs to stand out for I can't wait to
see him do more roles like this and yeah
he and he was scary cast Bill Hader
because he said he loved him and you can
tell because he gave him the best out of
everything in this movie okay so you
mentioned comedy and drama hard to pull
off separately when you have to unite
them into one performance that's a very
tall task you're about to go to a lot of
film festivals Jonathan lives in a place
where they have a prestigious Film
Festival where you have award buzz start
to be generated is there any chance Jack
I'm gonna start with you your boy Bill
Hader anybody else in the cast could
there be Oscar nominations in their
future you know I will never say never
because people put ad campaigns behind a
lot of different things but I don't
think so for this one and I would be the
first one to vote for him let me put
that out there I would be the very first
one to vote for any category Bill Hader
is in but I think he's going to be well
taken care of at the Emmys and the
Golden Globes with Barry which is still
certified fresh' 100
at Rotten Tomatoes a hundred percent
well Jonathan we know that it chapter 2
is gonna have no shortage of dollars to
put behind a possible Oscar campaign do
you see that happening this year I
honestly don't I again I think it's a
perfectly fine movie again it is flawed
I think there are some categories where
might get some nominations but none of
the big ones I could see maybe makeup
maybe costume design potentially
production design but apart from that
I'm not gonna see any best actor actress
anything like that maybe an adapted
screenplay anything else that you see
Joel not that I think so I think I think
that's one thing that Jonathan raises is
the production design this is a
beautiful looking film this is
incredibly well shot incredibly
well-crafted and a machete just does
there are sequences in this film that
are just you're like oh you're a
masterful director and I can't wait to
see what you do next because you know I
think it's great I think no on the
acting front I think they're great
performances I just don't think it's
that kind of film although that kind of
performance is really and I don't know
that the films gonna cut through in that
way I do think one thing we should say
though is he's playing this role over
two films is that bill skarsgård is
actually very good as penny wise he's
great he has one of my favorite like fun
factoids about the it franchise is that
they're trying to figure out how to do
the CGI with penny wise eyes and Bill's
leg you know I can just do that with my
it just
that's an incredible performance that I
think should be worthy of some sort of
award coming up later on this year but
the one thing we know about it chapter
two is it it's gonna make gobs of money
at the box office and anytime the movies
that successful you have to put on your
studio had Joel and say is there any way
we can continue this can we make a
sequel can we make a prequel is there
any way we can get people back into a
theater for another it movie should that
be the case and if so what direction we
taken in it okay well first editor of
rotten tomatoes never puts on his stereo
hat if I had to put myself in the
mindset I would say oh yes if this movie
makes a lot of money I imagine they will
come up with a reason to extend
and this story or reach back into this
story I think the thing about this film
is that it's one of those Stephen King
adaptations that King approves of
apparently approves of enough to like
show up for what felt like a 45-minute
cameo and has been very publicly out
there saying that this is a he likes
this it's a to take on this thing I can
see him george RR martin inning martin
ting it as the sort of lettuce seasons
of Game of Thrones and potentially
mapping out a story for this to continue
I think they'd have to go back because I
think if you went 27 years in the future
and we were like hovercars and [ __ ] and
might be a bit I'm scary so I look if
this movie makes even half of what the
first movie made which is the most
successful horror film of all time yes I
I don't see us I don't see this being
the end of it
yeah Jacqueline I don't see this movie
doing anywhere near as well as the first
it just because the first it was such a
phenomenon I think the running time of
this film I think that it's not gonna
have the tomato meter that the first one
did I think I still think it'll do well
well enough to warrant a sequel or a
prequel how would you feel about that
well I mean this is Warner they have
Warner media's about to launch their new
streaming service I do think if we do
tell new stories it'll probably be on
the streaming platform
maybe we'll get a Pennywise sequel let's
not forget we have Castle Rock which is
on Hulu which is this whole Stephen King
universe which they are still playing
around with Stephen King carriage is a
skarsgård guests cameoed in the first
season or a second season I think I'm
not sure but yeah it's it's already
there's already a groundwork for them to
do this on the small screen I think
that's where they'll go yeah I'd be up
for a penny wise prequel I want to see
what happened how do you actually get
into that that that that clown facade
that this ancient spiritual supernatural
being has perpetrated Jonathan should we
see anything more from it on the big
screen or on a streaming platform so I
did have an idea on where they could
take this that I think would I think it
would just be an interesting way to go
about it and I'll fully admit that this
is an idea stolen from the video game
Alan Wake
but basically
I think what should happen is Bill is
becomes a much better writer moving
forward because of the events of the
this of this you know it losers Club
defeating Pennywise what what happens is
the better books that he writes start to
become the manifestation of new horror
stories that are powered by the entity
that essentially created Pennywise so it
you can then go into new king worlds or
new king ideas with that same foundation
but without having to rely upon
Pennywise who we've now seen for two
movies and we kind of don't need to see
him kind of deflate into himself once
again I kind of like that calling in in
the mouth of madness maybe like things
are you know the dark half that things
start to manifest around just because
you you are this brilliant author and
you see a lot of Stephen King himself in
that character so Jonathan I want to
stick with you and then throw it to the
couch where where does this movie rank
in your favorite Stephen King adaptation
films and what is your all-time best oh
wow that's a great way to put me on the
spot um I will say that it's it's gonna
rank probably in the top I would say 10
to 15 my personal favorite would be the
shining even though I'm aware that King
himself is not a big fan but yeah it
would it would probably be in the top 10
to 15 okay I had the pleasure doing a
versus I had the pleasure doing an
episode earlier this week that was
ranking the Stephen King movies we
bracketed them from 1 to 16 the highest
on the tomato meters how we seeded them
and I'm not gonna tell you what I
arrived at but Joe I'd like to get your
take and then Jacqueline's best Stephen
King adaptation film that's in the
horror genre and then where you would
put it chapter 2 again it's a boring
answer but the shining I think it's just
it's it's so masterfully done
performances I think misery is you know
do we consider that part of the horror
genre I will for the purposes of this
discussion definitely a close second for
me Kathy Bates incredible
feet ankles ow I'm just you know I think
that's such a well done film this film
you know as much as I sort of pointed
out some of the flaws they are flaws
within a three-hour context and I
actually enjoyed this film a lot I may
have enjoyed this more than part one
because I found that part one was was
was was really solid and tight but I
liked some of the risks and weirdness in
this film a little bit more and I
actually think this film is scarier than
part one overall and so I think this
would probably be in my top six or seven
of the horror genre because you know
Carrie Missouri The Shining Christine
then then you're sort of getting you're
struggling a little bit once you get
past the classics I think to find
something that matches it and yet
chapter 10
yeah Kuja yeah Cujo kudos in the top
sixteen I'll say that the 1989 Pet
Sematary I'll say this if if Pennywise
was to haunt me the manifestation
pennyways would want to take would be
Zelda from 89s Pet Sematary because I
saw the movie in the theater at far too
young an age so my personal favorite
would still be that original Pet
Sematary
Jacqueline Coley where does it chapter
to fall in the King Pantheon I mean I'm
so sad that we're sticking to just hard
because Dark Tower hello actually as
much as I enjoy the shining I loved
Carrie I saw that movie and I just felt
like as a woman and just her like going
through high school it was terrifying
but also so realistic and it was
terrifying in a different way it was
terrifying and how awful people can be
to each other like just the awfulness of
humanity and as much as I like The
Shining unfortunately I saw that movie
too late for it to have the impact that
it had on other people because by the
time I saw it I knew everything that was
happening so it wasn't a scary scene of
them twister yeah I mean yeah pretty
much
yes exactly a twister but I'd seen all
the big moments through the pop culture
lexicon and so it didn't it didn't scare
me as much but I carry was definitely
turned it on what is this the chloë
grace moretz personnel button on this
conversation I think that Joel said it
best when he had the most accurate
summation of misra I've ever heard feet
ankles Wow that is gonna do it for us
here today
on the after-show I want to thank my
winners for joining me today on the
panel make sure that you guys check out
the after-show you can subscribe to the
Rotten Tomatoes YouTube channel right
now leave a comment we want to hear from
you is it chapter 2 better than the
first one where does it rank and your
all-time favorite Stephen King horror
film adaptations and hit that Bell right
now that's gonna give you an alert every
time we have a new after show to drop
the big movie comes out we're gonna be
talking about it right here until next
time we'll see you then
[Music]